so here at the Soho Theatre with Joe
Dempsie he's starring an even stillness
breathe softly against a brick wall Joe
it's your London debut on the stage
isn't it how you finding it it's been
great so far actually I sort of theatres
something that I've wanted to do for a
really long time it's it can be quite
tough medium to break into actually
because there are so many talented
actors out there that are doing great
work on stage already so if it can be a
bit of a catch-22 sometimes if you know
there are people that have loads more
experience than you and they might end
up getting a lot of the parts kind of
for ahead of you so I was really glad
that given the opportunity to to give it
a go with such a great and interesting
script because I'm sort of always said
that in terms of the work that I do I'm
the medium isn't something that overly
concerns me is that I always feel like I
want to do stuff that's just original
and and sort of challenging and and and
and yeah and and kind of divisive in
ways as well and I think this display
absolutely fits the bill as far as
that's concerned so it's and it's it's
hard work you know my housemates were
sort of delighted that I was suddenly
having to get up at a normal time and
couldn't just sit in my pants watching
Sky Sports News every day so yeah the
first week of rehearsals hours you know
I was coming back and moaning that you
know 9:00 to 5:00 is a really really
rubbish but it's been it's been really
fun I've enjoyed every minute of it
people who haven't seen it yet but tell
them what it's about and what your
character is in the in the play as well
this is always a difficult one but the
play is essentially it's a two hander so
there are two characters called him and
her I play him guessing and they're a
couple who essentially that you know the
first half of the plays that is them
describing their daily routine to the
audience and over the course of the play
they they sort of realized just how much
they hate it and how much they've been
kind of just putting up with a lot of
that the baggage that comes with with
with modern life and and and and kind of
led by him due to a kind of a an
encounter with it with a work colleague
they start developing this philosophy
about about how to shut all of that all
of those unwanted outside influences now
they realize that the only things they
really care about each other the only
things they really care about are each
other and so well how do they need
anything else really and so that's when
the play takes a sort of quite different
turn and and they start seeing what they
what happens if they push the boundaries
a little bit and they're both very much
characters who are quite in their own
heads in a way aren't they as I guess
many people are in Modern Life and
that's what the message I guess it's a
play there's a lot of anxiety a lot of
worried thinking about what people are
thinking about them did you identify
with any of those parts of your
character yes I did actually mean I
think I think I think modern modern
living is given us all so many more
neuroses and I guess Alex people didn't
worry about all this stuff in like the
1800s but but and and yeah and I
identify with with the whole you know
him he more him more than her seems to
be more paranoid about what his
colleagues think of him and and and how
he's how he's perceived and and and and
whether he is perceived as someone who
was successful or rich eveing to his
full potential I think he realizes after
a while he's definitely not but and and
I I sort of do all that to a certain
extent I think I think I kind of grew
out of it a little bit after my sort of
teens I was quite self-conscious in my
teens but it so it's in a way it's
harking back to that a little bit and I
think because there is something about
him that is quite he is kind of a little
bit adolescent in ways and I think and
and then the fun side of that comes out
as well towards the latter stages of the
play where you know he just really
starts trying to mess with people's
minds and and and indulging that in a
delinquent
there's a great line here's a new player
you have is him in the play as well
about him you know whose business my
business Studies degree didn't prepare
me to meet it's inconsequential I've got
loads of friends the Business Studies
degrees at University so and really
can't wait for them to see this play
yeah but and I think I think that is
getting so symbolic of of you know the
age that we live in and specifically now
you know I'm as I just said a lot of my
friends went to university to do
Business Studies or business related
courses and that was because you know we
all applied during the time of this time
of you know unending act and I had
economic prosperity and then all of a
sudden the recession hit while they were
in first year I think and it just still
kind of went downhill for everybody and
you know we were all everyone was sold
this dream of getting a degree in being
headhunted by some big finance company
in the city and living on you know 150
grand a year and it didn't really happen
for anyone and they came out and
struggled to get jobs at all you know in
you know Pizza Express let alone you
know a big high flying multinational and
of course there's a lot of politics in
the play a lot of kind of looking at the
society we live in now but it's also it
has a lot of humor as well doesn't as a
heck of a lot of humor you haven't well
I think it's just I think it's essential
because it can be and that and we worked
on that quite a lot cuz you know Brad is
such a he's a really funny guy and and
you have to imbue his writing with with
that's the same sense of humor that he's
got because there's one way that you can
read the play which is completely just
abject cynicism the whole way through
you know it's laden with it but I think
if you deliver it all in that way then
it can make an get quite OneNote and I
think because it's just two characters
and it is so intense and the space is so
claustrophobic you have to have some of
that sort of light relief in there and I
also think you have to you have to like
these two people as well at least to a
certain extent at the beginning to buy
into their journey into kind of and to
root for them so um so yeah they keep
the humors something that we
we worked on quite a bit and tried to
kind of give it that sort of give that
initial sense of you can be cynical but
still have a sense of hope you know
yourself this is this is how my life is
and it's [ __ ] but what can you do and so
I'm glad that that comes across
you mentioned the space those well is a
very intimate space of it I think works
perfectly for this play doesn't it I
don't I don't think you could do it in
space much bigger to be honest I think
it's as I just mentioned that the
claustrophobia of this apartment is key
to to to audiences feeling that that
that sort of same sense of nowhere
unease really and and it's been good for
us as well to keep it I think it's not
the kind of play as well that you
because there is so much dialogue you
don't want to have to shout too loud
it's a be heard and obviously it's
someone who's done a lot of them you
know mostly screen work in the past it's
great for me having not been Terada I
don't have to project too much Thanks
and now you've also got a co-star in
there the hair of the title is Laura
Rossi who you worked with before haven't
you in murder TV drama what's it like
working with her again but on stage and
also you worked with a friend who's the
director haven't you - yeah well I think
that's what's made this this so perfect
for me in many ways in a fit with it
being my first play and it being you
know quite challenging material and they
can--it and a big ask we've kind of done
it without thinking about it but then
when I do think about I'm sure most of
the plays will seem like a walk in the
park compared to this but you know the
what's made it a lot easier has been the
fact that we've been working with such
good friends already you have known
Nadia for a couple of years now socially
and then having worked with Lara last
year it's as you as you know it's that
it's the kind of play where the less
breaking of the ice you have to do
before you get started the better and
and there was none to do with with Lara
cos you know we'd spent a couple of
weeks up in Edinburgh last
filming and it was weird how the roles
have kind of reversed Lara was quite
nervous on set last shaker she had an
awful lot of screen work and it was you
know very much her kind of asking us
what to expect and now the roles have
completely reversed you know I'm working
with it you know seasoned pro when it
comes to stage and and and I'm the one
that's nervous to do things like singing
on stage or or eating that sandwich do
you try and keep it a bit different for
yourself each night are you always
thinking the same song do you have a
different sandwich interesting I don't
know weak insistence he's been the key
for me anyway again I did that I'm glad
that you've described it singing I'm not
sure many in the audience would go that
far but but now we there are all things
I think that's another yeah the weird
thing about this is it's I look back on
it and you know I look at what we what
we do every night and and it's pretty
nuts but we've all just we'll just kind
of cut on with it without really
thinking about it I think that's the
only way to approach a play like this
you know I think if you if you're if
you're an actor that note that that
thinks about those kind of things too
much you're kind of going to be a bit
screwed with this one now without giving
away what happens and the latter part of
play do you find what does happen
cathartic at all that's a good question
I mean I think I think the the
interesting thing about the play is that
it it challenges it makes people
challenge their daily routines and it
makes people question whether they're
happy in their lives and whether they
need to kind of be part of this this is
of never ending rat race for kind of
want of a better term I think the really
the really interesting thing about it is
that they so the characters trying to
find a way to break free from that and
and it is and to watch I imagine it's
really quite empowering and quite
liberating seeing them kind of just take
this kind of really nihilistic route but
whether it actually works or not and
whether they're actually whether either
of them actually happy or any better by
the end of it is
is really it's really ambiguous and and
and you know I'm not sure if they are so
it's so it's kind of it's kind of yeah
making a mockery of modern society
whilst also saying that you know you
probably not them any better if you try
to do something different it was
certainly an interesting play it's all
these different aspects to it you
mentioned your TV work their relation to
law as well and working ahead last year
and obviously this is a very intimate
production and one of the things you
know you for so well now is a very vast
production isn't it which is Game of
Thrones have you found working on season
three of that compared to the previous
two seasons season three I mean I see
season three of Game of Thrones
hopefully how I'll see my third play I
do you know you get more and more
comfortable with every every year that
goes by already it so it took me a good
couple of seasons to to come to terms
with or to get my head around the scale
of the thing you know it's huge on you
know I've spent years kind of shooting
on location in the dark where now there
are lighting guys putting lights up on
poles and making sure they're all angled
in the right place so that it can hit
you properly and then you get to Game of
Thrones and they don't bother with that
they have a helium-filled limp of light
middle of the sky at their own Sun and
and so it took me a while to it took a
while for the nerves to settle but then
once you get to know everyone it's just
great if you feel you feel as
comfortable and as relaxed as you would
be on you know the smallest of the
smallest of film sets and and so I've
really enjoyed season three and
especially because I feel like
personally I've been I've been entrusted
with evermore as this series have
progressed and they've even started
writing you know new storylines for my
character that don't appear in there in
the novels which is a really nice kind
of show of faith and seal of approval
sort of thing and and also I've made so
many friends on Game of Thrones that's
been that's been the main way in which
my life has changed as a result of the
show I think in terms of my day-to-day
existence I know I look so different in
real life you can
so how I'm seen in the in the program
that I think I don't really get stops or
recognized but I've just made it loads
and loads of mates and and it's great
you've got it kind of nice team we had a
lovely team didn't you on Game of
Thrones with Arya and hot pie and of
course Maisie Williams and Ben hawky we
seen you broken up now do you think
you'll ever get back together again
would you like it to come back together
again I mean I'd love yeah I'd love
Gondry Irie and hot pie it's sort of
former you know a badass outlaw and I've
movement and take the throne by whatever
force necessary not quite sure it's what
George Martin has in mind but but you
but the amazing thing is that you just
now that you really never know
everyone's kind of in the dark and I
think and the fact that even with the
stuff that's contained within the books
you know as I just mentioned they're not
David Benioff and Dan Weiss aren't
afraid to go off piste a little bit it
just keeps everyone on their toes you
you really don't know what's what's
gonna happen and it was great working
with Maisie and Ben and then and it was
really sad to to sort of have to leave
that the pair of them but but I always
think that wherever wherever genji at
least initially up until this point
wherever Gendry has has been seen it's
always been with Aria and it's always
been has a kind of foil for Aria and I
think you were only ever really gonna
get to find out more about Gendry that
the person when he struck out on his own
a little bit so hopefully that will
continue and working with Maisie we
actually spoke to Maisie recently and
she said he asked her who the biggest
prankster on set she said Ben hawky but
you AG human so what you have to say
over yeah I just like make the
cannonballs and custom to Bernsen that's
a fire
well it's a great thing about those two
is that I'm it doesn't matter how many
jobs I do I'm still terrible at getting
up in the mornings like I'm really bad
and then and so I'll often sort of
arriving on set just eyes barely open
but within it's like having it's like
having kids basically that within a few
minutes they're mucking around and
they've got you on your toes again and
see I've been I mean the amount of times
we nearly couldn't shoot a scene because
Ben was mucking about and still making
us laugh or doing some Family Guy
impression of something was honestly
lost count but but it's also just great
watching for me sound like I may sound
like a parent here but with all of the
youngsters who I think they cast so well
on Game of Thrones because I think in
any film or TV show that you watch it
doesn't matter how good everyone else is
if the if the kids are a bit of rubbish
it always kind of just slightly colors
your your judgement of the thing as a
whole and you get a great performance
from a from a you know a young actor and
it could certainly take everything to a
whole other level so everyone's
brilliant but it's it's been great for
me watching them grow up you know you're
you're getting to hang out with them in
the most formative years of their lives
and every year that you come back
they've they're a little bit different a
little bit more adult you know have
their own opinions on things and just
been great loved every minute you
mention King Gendry though what kind of
King do you think he would make I think
I mean I genuinely and I'm not just
saying this because it would be so great
for me and I'd look really cool I think
you think he'd be a great King I think
he has javis has the blood of Robert
Baratheon in him and we've seen in
episodes come you know episodes past
that he's when he when he needs to fight
he can fight and I've always said about
Gendry that I've I feel is the kind of
person that's never started a fight in
his life but it certainly finished a few
and I think that's a that's a great
quality to have in a leader but I think
I think because of his tough upbringing
and his you know his uncertainty about
his ancestry in his past and the fact
that he's essentially spent most of his
life on the bottom rung of society I
think what that will give him over even
his own father is it's just a real a
real sense of compassion and you know a
real kind of I think I'd be a real
champion of the underdog and I think
he'd be I think it'd be a really fair
and just and just King and
you know you could want more than that
we hope well I hope he gets rid of
Melisandre very soon definitely yeah I
mean it wasn't it was certainly a
strange way to lose your virginity but I
think he knew what's I thinking what was
going on I think you know be real
rollercoaster of emotions for him that
but I thinking
again I think Ganges the kind of person
that he'll be more annoyed with himself
than with her you know that he was kind
of I don't think he sees himself as a
naive person because I think as he's
been growing up he's always had a lot of
street smarts I'm probably been able to
outwit a lot of the people that have
tried to get one over on him but now
he's moving into these upper echelon of
people that have been playing games for
years you know and just know how to
manipulate people so well and I think
everything's a learning care of him and
I don't think he'll be making the same
mistake twice no more leeches for you
then no no no it's that with Game of
Thrones you wonder how they're gonna do
certain things when I first read that
scene oh my obviously my first thought
was oh and how they're gonna do the
leeches they're gonna CGI them in or
something and I thought about it for
about two minutes and said no they're
gonna just put real leeches on the art
night and that's exactly what they did
it was well they were all they were all
fed so that was fine but then the result
of that was it they weren't really sort
of latching on so they just kind of just
slide off I was lying there yeah they
just sort of slide off me and I black is
it literally is it under my back now and
and yeah so it was it was fine it was
cool but I mean they asked me beforehand
they said which we just want to check
your um you're cool with leeches aren't
you right hung out with leeches before I
don't I don't know but it's one way to
find out
finally why should people come and see
even stillness at the Soho Theatre I
think in terms of even stillness I think
it's just it's a it's the kind of place
you know we've we've kind of discussed
the play and analyze the play length and
it's it's give me the kind of thing that
it's it's really not you know it's not
gonna be everyone's cup of tea but it's
certainly gonna make you whether whether
you buy into the the characters
philosophies or not it's certainly gonna
make you question
and a hell of a lot and question your
own mindset and your own kind of your
own life and your own daily routine and
I think it's um it's just there Brad
Birch's I think is destined for huge
huge things such an interesting writer
and for a guy that's only 23 to have all
these all these amazingly funny dark
interesting visceral thoughts running
through his head it's just really
remarkable and I think you know - the
main reason would be so you can tell all
your friends in like 10 years time that
you saw Brad birches first play and be
really smug about it and Joe Dempsie on
stage for the first time as well yeah
yeah yeah and that and and and and Lara
Rossi as well as just putting in a
fantastic performance and and I think
that's thing and it's it's been a lot of
lines for us to learn so it'd be great
if people came and watch the save them
you